deux questions importantes l'une que je
vais vous poser sur ce fichier qui a été
publiée dans le mystère l'intérieur qui
compile des données personnelles et
biométriques de de nous tous de tous les
français dans une seule base unique est
ce que pour vous le c'est un problème
pour les libertés fondamentales surtout
si ce fichier se retrouve dans les mains
dans notre gouvernement par exemple
c'est un problème essentiel je suis très
inquiète sur ce fichier et sur les
réponses que le gouvernement apporte aux
questions qui sont posées par les
députés là dessus car le gouvernement ne
dit pas la vérité mon il dit que la cnil
oui il ya une question par la vérité non
parce que la présidente de la cnil
madame falque perrotin a indiqué qu'elle
avait elle même de grandes inquiétudes
notamment sur le contrôle qui pouvait
être fait de ce fichier enfin c'est à
dire que elle souhaite qu'il y ait un
cours de 4 à la mairie terre de l'amorti
il a prétendu que la cnil était d'accord
avec ces faux riches et or ce n'est pas
le cas la présidente de la cnil a dit
que les contre pouvoirs n'était pas
suffisant et notamment qu'elle
souhaitait qu'il y ait un contrôle
parlementaire beaucoup de cela un très
bon point selon vous mais je voudrais
entre des quoi je pense que il faut
absolument revoir la manière dont on va
contrôler l'utilisation de ce fichier et
que notamment le pouvoir des
parlementaires soient renforcées mais il
faut en tout cas écouter la présidente
de la cnil